[Music]
you're a new show your show has
premiered actually a new location and I
might as well I think people know that
you're now doing your show from our old
set that we had at Universal which
worked out great for us I am on your old
stage no I don't feel great about it but
if someone should use me somebody should
use it oh yes a great stage is a
beautiful Pacific so thanks we put a lot
of work into that thing I was hoping
this wouldn't come up no I think it's
good I believe that airing these things
and I will I will credit you with I've
always thought that your show was very
funny and that you're very funny but you
did a hilarious bit on your show which I
think I think you used my old shower the
shower that I had when I was in that
state if that's the shower you use the
nest it is your old show this way it
doesn't have a lot of weird creams and
potions in there we cleaned it I did
they did a full scrubbing and everything
that's good there was a lot of residue I
love the word residue you guys went in
with a blue light okay well anyway you
did a great bit with with you and Sandra
Bullock yeah where you're both together
I don't think we were allowed to show
the bit but we have a photo about yeah
the shower that is hot she surprises me
in the shower
yeah I would have my yeah and and tells
me that I have to get my act together
for my new show that I'm gonna start
behaving like a real talk-show host do
you know somebody who's more responsible
like yourself instead of being such a
[ __ ] and sleeping with all my guests
it's not that I haven't tried to sleep
with my cat they're just like well
you're also married I'm not married so I
can sleep with whomever I want that's
true
and that's why I became a talk-show host
I would meet a different person every
day yes the biggest wasted opportunity
for me and all the boys who work on my
show all the writers like oh this is the
worst now we've gotten some recognition
now we're on television and we're all
married like we could have done this
while we were sitting home like I told
everyone not to get married I told
everybody we're gonna have huge
opportunities but I don't sleep with all
my guests I just sleep with some of
either rappers well that's you